[Musica]
siete pronti a vivere la storia più
bella di tutta la vostra vita cominciamo
porca [ __ ] non vedo più niente che è
una roba ragazzi ma [ __ ] bella
tutti ragazzi e poi minuti che sono
video sono fa vj e ci siamo subito
segrete le ansie le stava tentando
pronuncia inesistenti comunque ragazzi
siamo su greta minuto fallo che la
candela pro non vendo una sega questa
roba quindi si sarebbe un gioco di tipo
troll face quest ma non è tipo dove più
bello allora che non ha capito un attimo
c'è prima in the part one pietre pietra
come chiamare un capitolo che che che
suscita attenzione pietra che figo
ragazzi il mulino bianco ma la voce
banderas chiesto tizio c'è un tizio con
la testa uova e normale sta cosa
e c'è una tizia a caso sa che sta
facendo discutere così chi sono questi
perché il bambino sull occhio nero a mio
zio mi sono svegliato a premi il tasto
sinistro che devo posso approach a
muovermi perfetto possa andare in giro
che figata assurda come non detto
ragazzi non è un'amica come trofei quest
più figo ancora c'è un buco nel muro tra
l'altro up sori gare devo guardare
queste due persone mentre fanno le
sporcizie e lei le mestruazioni quindi
non posso ma cosa vuol dire che ha le
mestruazioni possiamo lo stesso ne sa
perché poteva avere dei bambini
potrebbero morire
ah ok portami del cibo uomo fame le
donne condono le loro cose sono
intrattabili comunque non lei a parte
gli scherzi ragazzi si sta si sta
lamentando la tizia perché vuole che lui
porti del cibo però il cibo non basta
per tutti quanti perché siamo in quattro
compresi bambini cioè hansel e gretel
che potremmo andare nella foresta
e lasciarli uccidere ma no ma se gli
stronzi così avremo avremo uscivo tutto
per noi ma sei una trottola per non dire
[ __ ] pro l'ho detto no non possiamo
farlo andiamo nella foresta cercare
tutti insieme poi li abbandoniamo ma sei
stronzo pro tour
ma dobbiamo ucciderli ma vaffan
questa è proposto ronza no sì no sì ha
vinto lei alla fine bisogna sì no dai
veramente ma volete abbandonare due
bambini perché non c'è il cibo per tutti
ma siete stupidi una ragazza sul serio
ma no non possiamo ha svegliati ansie e
veloce vogliono buttarci nella foresta
luca gamba scherzi ma perché per tizio
cia testa uovo non l'ho capita sta cosa
devo allora fatemi capire c'è una c'è
una fionda direi che devo prendere la la
fionda c'è una freccia che me la indica
quindi credo ecco perfetto ma che figlio
posso tirare controlli nokia figata
assurda pm che ha fatto la crepa non mio
dio come faccia uscire di qua mi
caricano il buco così prendo mentre
strombazzano alloggio qua sopra tra
l'altro che non so se vedete per come è
accaduto al beh posso posso controllare
lo hanno preso anche colpire movimento
la russa dai fastidio mentre rossi
stronzo è svegliato che mi già qualcosa
dobbiamo uscire zio ci sono i nostri
genitori che fanno bunga bunga e tu non
vuoi assistere al bunga bunga vero c'è
ok ho bucato finestre ragazze una mosca
ragazzi brega è entrato nei mosca
perfetto cioè a scadenza non importunare
mio fratello lurida e la lava baffa può
andare a demo beccarla terminati i
ragazzi non c'è verso ma come faccio a
lanciare le cose di sopra che sono sotto
al letto non è possibile
[ __ ] sì se l'è mangiata mio fratello
ma cosa stai bene tutto ma grossi cani
che ti sei mangiato una mosca ma cosa
hai da ridere vabbè se il mio idolo
incompreso che stai racconta mi caccia
ai un enfasi né a raccontarle cosa che
fa paura zia hai capito
si è capito tutto mi sa che
ho capito che mio fratello è un [ __ ]
questo ho capito è che c'è un fratello
deficiente cosa facciamo
stiamo cercando il modo di fuggire
perfetto ha vomitato sta roba comitato
no terminati 1 capito una bambola a
vomitare ad una bambola certo bene
perché se tocco mio fratello si abbassa
è chiaro che tanto ti becco uguale ecco
io ho fatto l'occhio nero ragazzi lo
stop over e non sta distruggendo e la
tua punizione per essere stupido mi
dispiace ma basta la vecchia poverino
basta ragazzi todd ridotto una merda
cerchiamo di fuji devo andare qua
cavalcato eh va beh come come faccio a
va lui a sposare lo sapevo che c'era un
passaggio una forma io lo sapevo pure
dove vai vai prima tuo no vado prima ma
che stai facendo zio
[Musica]
vado prima io ok non guardarmi sotto la
gonna pervertito bravo ce la fa uscire
mio fratello ti svegli e mio fratello
rimasto dentro però vabbè sono uscito io
posso suonare il campanello così esce
mio fratello perché sveglio tutti io
trovo delle cose a terra questo trovato
un sasso devo andare di qua ma io vado
avanti uno scoiattolo devo prima
liberare mio fratello sono col cazzo
cos'è una ragnatela
buongiorno un ragno della madonna
ok scolta zio se io ti picchia si
ragazzi non capisce una leva qui
purtroppo trovato un qualcosa che non ho
capito cosa ma perché c'è un ragno posso
accettarlo libro non mi caga di striscia
che è stronzo semmai vicino a quel coso
mi mangi vivono no perché sono una
bambina tanto tenera io cos'è cos'è
cos'è
no no no schiacciavo al sel che gesù ha
bisogno di aiuto sono sanguigna o mio
dio m p le brutte no è un rhythm ha
veramente ma ucciso ma che brutto è una
roba tragica questa questo trovato un
fungo a me a me servirebbe quella roba è
zio non ci hai voglia di passarmela in
qualche modo no ragazzi io torno
indietro che è meglio è stato orribile
sono ma buongiorno zio mi sono
innamorato del coniglio perfetto posso
prenderlo il coniglio bobby mi piace
come nome ti piace questo ragazzo e
stupro di coniglio ma mio zio lo molli
poi mollare
basta basta c'è un corvo tra che è
successo sta passando le ore la madonna
cosa sono morto perché ho giocato tutta
la vita con questo coniglio il senso di
questo gioco
qualcuno lo sa che una farfalla posso
prendere la farfa lo pestata ho pensato
non volevo giuro signor corvo posso
bacchetta le leader età non si grazie
se devo fare sui capi treno secchio
preso un secchio perche ascolta zio
coniglio buttare la moneta del boss la
moneta questo questo butta questo è
questo no questo il secchio secchio
ovviamente cosa ci andava nel pop sono
un deficiente sommesso delle ore a
capire che ci andava un secchio preso
una moneta
penso una cosa me ne faccio di stamane
filone capra anzi è una cosa che cosa
verrà [ __ ] losco vieni qua bastardo
bellissime le giornate in cui uno
scoiattolo ti fotte le monete questa
l'ho vista per miracolo cioè sardo
lurido pezze ragazzi non prenderò prima
o poi ok cielo ragazzi questa cosa mi
serve mettere una maniglia in un buco
tra posso premere anno giro la maniglia
perfetto adesso premo il pulsante ok ho
capito che ci devo andare lo scoiattolo
ma come ci va lo scoiattolo se non
l'atteso riuscito a prendere un ramo non
so come raga non chiedetemi come faccio
l'ho preso la potevi tornare dentro
ragazzi voglio vedere che fine ha fatto
mio fratello sta colorando giustamente
di seguirmi devi seguire da foto e
disegni bravo se funzionano stand
noccioline se perfetto ce l'ho fatta
ragazzo ha messo mezz'ora diventi
l'altro la giusti così dentro anche auto
tagliare ciò nessun macello ma donati
kiki l'uno di sé e che lo tu cosa fai
veloce ma iniziale riguarda che non ci
posso che il pulsante se ce l'ha fatta a
strozzo vivono messo anni per prendere
sta mica di moneta nel 7 adesso perché
fanno un cadere mio dio c'è riuscita
katniss in hunger games non ci riesco io
come faccio a far cadere stato col fungo
bilancio la marionetta con rama a
corriamo corriamo
beh sì merda che ci sono le cose che ci
sono queste cose brutte ap ascoltate ap
brutte devo prendere devo prendere cosa
sta succedendo mi hanno via via low ride
ragazzi hanno appunto seriamente cioè la
madonna che esagerazioni manova mio dio
fa caschi che schifo di cosa orribile ho
appena visto non gioca orribile quello è
molle morti che fai mi chiama manco
final destination ho capito con cosa le
con questo col tempo il fungo scuso col
fungo ho mangiato ho mangiato un fungo
che cosa succede
saggia molto saggio
mi chiamano conoscerlo in gol è una roba
siamo 8 su 10 da telecamere mancano due
è stata una cosa utile molto utile
soprattutto allora fatemi capire non
l'ultima che mi rimane all ultima la
penultima devo buttare ancora la
marionetta ma seriamente se se se l'è
presa se l'è presa si è incollato le
mani stupirla ciò fatta adesso posso
passare non ci posso credere ciò fatta
se si muove su di esso 6 stavamo un
pianoforte questo trova 10 su 10 ma come
10 su 10 o femmina ten ho capito dunque
successo mi sta dicendo che vuole andare
a fare una passeggiata stronza perché
dovevo andare a parare 6 dobbiamo dare
la farà passeggiata di morire lurida
qualcuno mi descrive questa scena con
una parola sola nei commenti [ __ ]
è la mia parola ho capito che devo
correre però il problema è che cosa devo
fare
ascoltami se ho capito che devi fare di
tutto per la passerà però mio dio
santissimo un po di contegno e raro vava
avere ascoltami già che c'è la testa
uova tell us parco o rido strano ma no
ma cosa devo prendere lei non lui
perfetto john si si
dai dai che siamo un piccione muori
piccione un impiccione cosa devo fare
uno stronzo non mi porterai via mio
fratello non rido tutta colpa tua
tutta ma si pranza che bene anche il si
sorseggia qualcosa nel mentre la
sorseggi che ti sorseggio la faccia
maledetta lo rilascia fatta 3 su 10 uno
schifo di totale praticamente ci aveva
fatta siamo sopravvissuti ragazzi stato
orribile però però va bene abbiamo fatto
ok sta dormendo che ma dove di preciso
credits finito e sono andati di preciso
i miei genitori ho persi va bene è stato
ri c'è anche la seconda parte ragazzi la
facciamo e non prossimo episodio fatemi
sapere se vi piace perché se non mi
piace non lavaggio
cos'è se c'è cos'è sta roba ragazzi in
c'è il corpo che si sta aprendo un
bastone su per il ok tubi continue
perfetto ma devi sapere ragazzi se
volete che io continui così faccio anche
il 2 diverso dal solito ma è bello cioè
mi è piaciuta la storia a parte quella
lurida [ __ ] ma quella è una tresca
nonché ragazzi cosa sento servito è
piaciuto lasciato questo mi piace anche
per la candela che si è spenta che se
non lo vedevo una sega asta che le
candele non fanno luce ma fap riduce la
mia luce server e city 7 ci fosse bello
ragazzi